[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Francis piner bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateur les
républicains de Paris vous êtes membre
du groupe d'amitié France Israël au
Sénat George mal Bruno bonjour merci
d'être avec nous journaliste spécialiste
du moyen r journaliste au Figaro Steve
est également avec nous je vous donne la
parole dans quelques instants on va
parler dans ce club de la projection des
images des attaques terroristes du Hamas
du 7 octobre c'était hier soir au Sénat
une cinquantaine de sénateurs y ont
assisté ils en sont ressortis
bouleversés vous y étiez Francis vous
nous direz comment vous avez vécu ce
moment et puis on parlera évidemment de
cet accord trouver cette nuit entre
Israël et le Hamas une trêve en échange
de libération d'otage Steve vous nous
direz ce qu'on sait de ces otages oui
alors il il y a très peu de choses pour
l'instant qu'on qu'on sait une liste
sera publiée normalement ce soir en
Israël on en parle tout de suite dans ce
[Musique]
club et on va commencer en parlant de
cette projection qui avait lieu hier
soir projection de ces images du 7
octobre de ces attaques terroristes du
Hamas Steve d'abord un mot sur la
jeunesse de ce film oui alors ce qui ce
qui est intéressant à noter c'est que
c'est pas l'habitude d'Israël de revenir
en général sur les attentats sur les
massacres qui sont euh ça s'explique par
l'histoire un peu du pays en général il
y a une attaque et y a un attentat et on
passe très vite à autre chose là c'est
un peu particulier l'armée israélienne a
décidé de monter ce film c'est un
israélien qui travaille dans la tech qui
a lui-même monté ses images il des
beaucoup de discussion sur est-ce que
l'opportunité de diffuser ou non ces
images notamment en Israël d'abord ça a
été diffusé à des journalistes ensuite
progressivement ça s'est élargi
notamment à des diplomates à des
responsables politiques ça a été diffusé
il y a de de semaines en Israël au
parlement israélien il y a une
cinquantaine environ de de députés
israéliens qui ont assisté à cette
projection alors 50 sur les 120 que que
compte la knisset ça a évidemment
bouleversé tous les députés il y avait
des députés aussi
israéliens et notamment du parti
islamiste RAM qui ont participé à cette
projection une projection qui est un peu
qui a été organisée un peu comme ce que
vous avez vu je pense hier au Sénat
c'est-à-dire que et bien il y avait on
devait mettre les téléphones avant de
rentrer dans la salle pour pas
qu'ensuite ces images soient diffusées
sur l'opportunité juste je termine la su
sur l'opportunité de diffuser ces images
il a encore des des des discussions
aujourd'hui en Israël Benyamin etanou
serait pour ouvrir encore ce film à un
plus large public les psychologues en
Israël disent non ce sont attention ce
sont des images très sensibles et qui
pourraent être aussi détourné donc il y
a encore des des discussions aujourd'hui
en Isra et on va parler de tout ça
Francis piner avant de nous dire comment
vous avez vécu ce moment et on va
regarder un peu ce qui s'est passé hier
soir est-ce que vous vous avez hésité
avant avant de prendre la décision
d'aller voir ce film alors moi je n'ai
pas hésité parce que
malheureusement ça fait très longtemps
que je suis avocat en matière criminelle
donc j'ai l'habitude de voir des photos
de corps
d'autopsie j'ai encore en
souvenir lorsque j'avais plaidé pour
Latifa ibziaten l'assassinat de son fils
tourné en GoPro et la mort de la petite
monsénégau donc je sais que
malheureusement ça fait partie de la
réalité du monde et qu'il faut toujours
regarder le monde en face ce qui est
effrayant évidemment dans ce que nous
avons vu hier c'est l'effet de masse
d'accumulation et
surtout lorsqu'on voit le crime mais
lorsqu'on voit la joie autour du crime
lorsqu'on voit les
assassins d'habitude nous on découvre le
crime et puis il y a l'enquête là on
voit l'assassin en action qui se
glorifie on voit un certain nombre
d'images oui qui sont on va on va
vous les avez vu vous George malbrunau
ces images vous ne souhhaaitiez pas les
voir vous n'avez pas eu l'occion on
l'ambassade d'Israël m'a proposé de les
voir mais j'étais pas disponible ce
jour-là on note correspondant le
correspondant du figuero à Jérusalem les
les a vu voilà sont les images j'imagine
insoutenable et oui ouais on va voir ce
qui s'est passé hier soir des sénateurs
qui sontessortis marqués de cette
projection comme l'a constaté notre
journaliste Jérôme
Rabier ils sont une cinquantaine de
sénateurs à avoir répondu du présent
pour assister à la projection du film de
l'armée israélienne montrant les
massacres du Hamas du 7 octobre une
diffusion à H clos chacun devant laisser
son téléphone portable à l'entrée c'est
le président du groupe d'amitié France
Israël du Sénat qui en était
l'organisateur et pour ceux qui étai là
la nécessité d'y assister pour témoigner
c'est parce que je crois que nous devons
accepter de voir la réalité même si elle
est difficile à regarder même si elle va
nous imposer probement des moments
difficiles mais nous sommes là parce que
nous devons aussi faire comprendre au
monde ce qui s'est vraiment passé le 7
octobre en Israël une version de 52
minutes a été projetée et à la sortie un
silence totale et une émotion
palpable mais j'ai simplement vu
jusqu'où l'homme pouvait perdre l'âme ni
plus ni moins
c'est il y a pas de mot voilà c'est
c'est c'est pas des hommes qui ont fait
ça c'est
terrible il sera le seul sénateur à
s'exprimer à notre micro les autres
choisissant de ne pas le faire
immédiatement trop marqué par cette
diffusion ou ne voulant pas réagir à
chaud à un montage difficilement
soutenable selon les mots de sénateur
hors caméra Francis spiner comment vous
avez vécu la projection de ces
images
a il y a quelqu'un qui a parlé et qui a
dit que c'était pas humain et je pense
que malheureusement c'est très humain et
donc il faut
s'interroger toujours sur la capacité de
l'homme à commettre de telles
atrocités d'autant plus que ces
atrocités elles sont commises par des
gens fiers de les commettre et
donc on se dit
que quand on sort
il faut éviter d'être dans la haine
parce que quand vous voyez ces images
vous comprenez l'envie de haine et de
vengeance c'est le risque c'est c'est ce
que disait notamment Aurélien Pradier
votre collègue député LR qui disait que
lui il avait pas voulu y assister parce
qu' il avait peur du coup que ça fasse
naître un sentiment de
vengeance écoutez je va pas commenter
monsieur Pradier ses états d'âes mais
est- et sa capacité ça ne m'intéresse
pas mais est-ce qu'il y a ce risque
la vue de ces
images a toujours il y a toujours le
risque que les gens voyant ça se disent
et ben on peut raser Gaza ça pose aucun
problème quand vous voyez par exemple
les gens revenir avec le corps d'une
gamine avec un cadavre et la foule de
Gaza piétiné
oui vous vous dites les assassins et
leurs crimes sont fêés et glorifiés donc
ça vous entraîne forcément dans l'idée
tous coupabl et donc oui c'est il faut
les regarder parce qu'il faut voir la
réalité en face mais il faut avoir le
non pas le recul parce que le mot serait
un peu dérisoire mais il faut avoir
quand on est responsable politique la
tête froide et de dire ce crime a existé
ce crime devra être puni mais à
l'arrivée ce n'est pas la force qu'il
emportera d'une manière ou d'une autre
georgeembruneo Steve le rappel il y a un
débat sur l'opportunité ou non montrer
ces images est-ce que pour vous il faut
les diffuser ces
images j'ai pas d'avis tranché mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas c'est c'est
une réalité elle est
abjecte elle est euh
oui elle est elle elle est surprenante
dans la mesure où le Hamas a moi j'ai
j'ai été basé 10 ans à Jérusalem je l'ai
rencontré souvent à Gaza avec perpétré
dans les années 95 2000 2003 des
attentats terroristes horribles contre
des bus mais ça n'atteignait pas ce
degré de de de violence et cetera donc
oui c'est c'est un témoignage c'est un
témoignage on peut pas c'est une réalité
après effidtivement il y a le risque il
y a le risque de de comme vous l'avez
bien dit effectivement de de donc de de
de de de percevoir ça et de d'approuver
une vengeance et cetera
euh c'est oui oui c'est c'est alors oui
quand vous voyez évidemment le
dénis des gens de la France insoumis par
exemple vous avez envie de leur dire bon
maintenant arrêtez ce que vous dites est
obsène parce que voilà ce qui s'est
passé bon oui tout façon montrer la
vérité ne nuit jamais mais après je
pense que ça doit être
montré j'allais dire
ouais d'une manière qui soit faite dans
des conditions convenable voilà vous
avez pu tout regarder vous hier où il y
a des moments où c'est c'était trop dur
j'ai j'ai tout regardé et
euh oui il y a des moments après chacun
paradoxalement quand vous voyez des des
photos de de corps brûlé c'est c'est
horrible mais quand vous voyez les gens
qui s'en réjouissent c'est encore
pillant non ça je voulais juste dire ça
a été ces images ont aussi été diffusées
hier à l'ONU il y a eu environ 300
diplomates qui ont assisté à ces images
donc ça participe évidemment à à la
bataille des opinions publiques en
Occident alors en Israël aussi puisque
ça a été diffusé comme je l' rappelé il
y a 2 semaines mais aussi à la bataille
de l'opinion publique à l'échelle
internationalege oui on est
effectivement dans une guerre de
communication je pense qu' il faut il
les montrerement mais il faut aussi
montrer il y a eu le crime abject la
barbarie du 7 octobre mais il y a depuis
un certain nombre de de jours et de
semaines il y a ce qui se passe à Gaza
et becoup de victimes civiles je crois
qu'il faut montrer toutes les victimes
civiles de ce de cette de cette guerre
sinon on perd notre cré crédibilité quoi
moi je veux bien qu'on montre tout mais
il y a quand même des différences de
nature ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre
c'est une organisation terroriste qui a
décidé de s'en prendre aux femmes aux
enfants aux civils et de les tuer parce
qu'ils étaient israélien et juifs c'est
un crime délibéré scandaleux la
hariposte israélienne sur Gaza c'est un
acte de guerre avec malheureusement des
dommages qu'on appelle 10 collatéraux et
avec aussi le fait que le Hamas a la
fâcheuse tendance à se servir de sa
population comme bouclier humain alors
tous les morts se valent le gamin qui
meurt à Gaza c'est aussi triste que le
gamin qui meurt dans le kibutz mais les
causes et les raisons qui ont amené à
cette mort ne sont pas les mêmes et les
responsabilités ne sont pas les mêmes
voilà George malbruno làdus et et sur le
fait que la Hamas se sert des
palestinens oui oui non non mais je suis
d'accord avec vous mais comme l'a dit le
président la
République la vie d'un Israélien
équivaut à la vie d'un Français équivaut
à la vie un Palestinien sinon sinon on
on crée on crée un fossé et on et on
participe à importer un conflit ce qu'on
ne veut pas donc je suis d'accord avec
vous il y a y a il y a eu un attaqué un
attaquant comme il y avait avant et en
encore un occupant et un occupé donc il
faut à la fois prendre du recul
contextualisé mais vous avez raison les
causes ne sont pas les mêmes mais on ne
peut pas je je pense on ne peut pas dire
on montre ça et on ne montre pas ça il
faut montrer et expliquer comme vous
l'avez dit et expliquer aussi expliquer
aussi le 7 octobre dire le Hamas n'est
pas né le 6 octobre donc voilà il faut
montrer et il faut contextualiser alors
un côté juste technique c'est que on n
pas tellement d'images de Gaza pour une
raison simple c'est que il a pas de
journaliste à Gaza alors il y a aussi
attendez quand vous dites qu'il faut pas
importer le conflit il est déjà importé
d'abord il faut s'interroger aussi sur
la nature du conflit soit vous
considérez que c'est un
conflit de territoire
entre israélien et
Palestiniens soit vous considérez que
c'est un conflit entre une organisation
totalitaire qui fait d'ailleurs le
malheur des Palestiniens qui vivent sous
le pression du Hamas depuis des années
et que ce mouvement totalitaire s'en
prend en réalité à un régime
démocratique car quelles que soient les
imperfections les critiques qu'on peut
faire sur la politique israélienne
Israël reste une démocratie et en
réalité ce
totalitarisme ce qui s'est passé
lorsqu'on massacre ces jeunes israéliens
lors de la rêve partie c'est exactement
le batlan et ce sont les mêmes causes et
les mêmes motivations et si on fait
cette lecture là
à ce moment-là le conflit est déjà chez
nous oui mais le conflit maître vous
connaissez l'histoire c'est un conflit
territorial ça n'est pas un conflit de
civilisation contre d'cord je suis pas
d'accord AC vous mais mais vous avez
tort parce que c'est un conflit
historique je partage pas
territorial le processus de paix de
d'Oslo était basé sur l'échange de la
terre contre la paix c'est un conflit
territorial il y a des résolutions de
l'ONU vous êtes avocat il y a des
résolutions de l'ONU qui ont été adopté
en 1967 après la guerre des séjours qui
demande à Israël de se retirer il faut
partager la terre après plus on on
retarde le règlement de ce conflit plus
ce conflit va devenir effectivement un
conflit parfois religieux parfois
civilisation mais on est sur un conflit
territorial il faut pas en sortir sinon
on ne trouvera jamais vous ne pouvez pas
dire que le Hamas le Hamas est une
partie du mouvement palestinien islamisé
comme le hzbollah n'ont pas envie de
partager Hezbollah n'est pas un
mouvement palestinien non non mais
je parlais islamiste oui oui je dis tout
simplement que ces deux mouvements
contestent le droit même à
l' donc c'est pas une question de
territoire ah si si si c'est question
TER non c'est la question que on veut
sur cette terre instaurer une république
islamique avec tout ce que ça comporte
maître ce que je disais à mes amis
israéliens sur leur chaîne de télévision
avant leur dit quelle stratégie
avez-vous pour la bande de Gaza etchance
de 15 ans quand j'étais en Israël il y a
le la bande de Gaza le le les roquettes
du Hamas 1 km et demi de porté la
population de Gaza était de 1 million
d'habitants tout ça a été bouclé
aujourd'hui la population est 2 million
et demi d'habitants les roquettes c'est
150 km et si on n pas une vision
stratégique un petit peu de la bande de
et je leur disais vous allez créer un
hzbolabis au sud de de de chez vous et
donc si vous voulez il faut régler ce
problème et c'est un problème de
territoire ça n'est pas un problème mais
plus on va attend plus après le Hamas on
aura daesh il faut rappeler quand même
parce que c'est dans des faits
historiques en 2008 le Hamas en 2007 le
Hamas a pris le contrôle de la bande de
Gaza en 2008 il y a eu des souches
djihadistes qui sont apparu à Gaza qu'a
fait le Hamas le Hamas a combattu ces
sou islamistes qui sont allés dans le
Sinaï donc le Hamas est un mouvement
terroriste mais c'est un mouvement
politique aussi qui veut prendre le
contrôle sur la scène palestinienne qui
a une charte qui prône la destruction de
l'État d'Israël qui a été amendée en
2010 7 en des termes un peu plus édul
cororé voilà c'est ça qu'il faut dire et
donc si on ne règle pas le problème
palestinien par un échange de la paix
contre la terre parce qu'il y a pas
d'autre solution sauf à transférer les
Palestiniens ou qu' a un tremblement de
terre qui élimine une des deux
populations il faut pas le souhaiter et
bien il faut revenir à ces fondamentaux
là c'est ce que disent les Américains
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pourtant pas des
une puissance anti-israélienne voilà
après on peut pour vous répondre mais
qu'est-ce qu'a fait le Hamas de
Gaza depuis depuis 2006 2007 qu' sans
partage en ayant éliminé physiquement
leurs oppositions y compris celle du
fata en étant opprimé la population
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait est-ce qu'ils
ont développé Gaza benah ils ont géré le
état avec l'aide du Qatar et avec la
sentiment d'Israël oui mais ils n'ont
rien fait bah non ils nont pas fait ils
ont fait ce que font les pays arabes
c'estàdire ils ont gouverné à la manière
d'une petite autocratie voilà mais
est-ce que paradoxalement avec
l'assentiment d'Israël et des États-Unis
et de la communauté internationale
paradoxalement ce qui se passe depuis le
7 octobre n'a pas relancé la nécessité
de trouver une solution politique qui
est un peu m ce qui est terrible c'est
que c'est ce ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'on avait une situation qui qui était
de non guerre ni paix qui convenait à
Israël Benjamin netaniaou a dit les
déclarations officielles il faut faire
monter le Hamas pour affaiblir
l'Autorité palestinienne pour qu'il n'y
ait plus de possibilité de créer un État
palestinien entre ces deux territoires
qui ne sont pas contigu donc voilà on a
joué un peu avec le feu et et et et ce
qui est terrible aujourd'hui c'est que à
la faveur entre guillemets de cette
barbarie du 7 octobre et bien on se rend
compte que la cause palestinienne qu'on
avait oublié qu'on avait voulu oublier
que les chancellererie occidentale avait
voulu oublier ne voulait pas voir et
bien elle existait toujours et elle
existera encore demain et le Hamas sera
probablement très affaibli à Gaza il
sera pas éradiqué mais il existera
encore en sjordanie donc il faut recréer
les conditions d'un chemin politique
c'est ce qu'essaent de faire les
Américains c'est ce qu'on va essayer de
faire après alors sera très compliqué
parce qu'il y a de la haine côté
israélien on peut les comprendre et il y
a de la haine côté palestinien parce
qu'aujourd'hui parce que j'entends
j'entends
brusquement toutes les chancelleries qui
n'ont rien fait qui n'ont rien vu se
jeter à nouveau en disant la solution
miraculeuse nous avons les deux états
bon moi je dis
euh il faut qui est chez les
Palestiniens le
Mandela et qui est chez les Israéliens
Declerc parce parce qu'on oublie qu'en
réalité pour qu' a eu Mandela il a fait
eu le courage de Declerc qui est le
grand oublié de l'histoire de la paix
qui régant en Afrique du Sud quand je
vois le paysage politique du
Moyen-Orient je ne vois pas le Mandela
palestinien et je discerne mal qui peut
être le Declerc israélien aujourd'hui
oui on va parler des otages puisque
c'est l'information de cette nuit Israël
qui a donc approuvé un accord visant à
obtenir la libération de 50 Otages aux
mains du Hamas en échange d'une trêve de
4 jours mais Israël prévient cet accord
ne signifie pas la fin de la guerre Yan
e
effé après 6 semaines d'angoisse enfin
l'espoir pour les otages et leurs
familles environ 240 personnes ont été
enlevées le 7 octobre le Hamas et Israël
confirme avoir chacun trouvé un accord
pour la libération d'une cinquantaine
d'entre eux le gouvernement a approuvé
les grandes lignes de la première étape
d'un accord selon lequel au moins 50
personnes enlevées des femmes et des
enfants seront libéré pendant 4 jours au
cours desqu il y aurait une acalmie dans
les combats une trêve négociée
conjointement par le Qatar qui travaille
depuis des semaines avec les États-Unis
et l'Égypte le début de cette pause sera
annoncé dans les prochaines 24 heures et
durera 4 jours sous réserve de
prolongation dans l'accord figure en
contrepartie la libération de
prisonniers palestiniens 10 otage contre
30 prisonniers des jeudi annonce un ha
responsable du Hamas ce matin la France
salue cet accord nous espérons qu'il y a
des Françis parmi eux et même si
possible parmi le premier groupe qui va
être libéré puisque ce doit être grâce à
une trêve des libération étagé nous
l'espérons j'ajoute nous y travaillons
nous travaillons d'arrachepied c'est
vraiment notre première priorité depuis
le début mais ces premiers signes de
répis ne signifient pas la fin des
combats Israël confirme sa volonté
d'éliminer le Hamas à l'issue de la
trêve et les terroristes ne désarmment
pas les dispositions de cet accord ont
été formulées conformément à à la vision
de résistance nous confirmons que nos
mains resteront sur la gâchette et que
nos bataillons triomphants resteront aux
Agay Joe Biden se dit ce matin
extraordinairement satisfait par
l'accord jeanemal Bruno benami netaniao
n'avait pas d'autre choix que de
conclure cet accord devant la
détermination de son opinion publique et
la mobilisation en faveur des otages non
il avait pas l'autre choix parce que il
y a il y a eu une prise d'otage de masse
et donc les les
240 Israël en détenus aux mains du Hamas
et d'autres groupes sont un élément de
l'équation de la la guerre et donc on
voit bien qu'il va ce qu'a dit
netaniaahou comme ce qu'a dit le le
Hamas on voit bien qu'il va y avoir une
une pause et que cet accord c'est tant
mieux n'est qu'une première étape mais à
l'issue de cette première étape il y
aura probablement une reprise des
affrontements mais je moi je la la
question que je me pose et je pense que
c'est la c'est c'est le c'est le le
l'élément essentiel de de cet accord qui
est quand même un accord important
parrainé par le Qatar avec un rôle
extrêmement important des États-Unis il
y aura probablement des détenus
binationaux israélo-américains qui
seront libéré c'est ce que ça ça
n'enclenche pas quand même quelque chose
une dynamique en vue de d'un d'un
apaisement ou en tout cas de de
libération d'autres otages parce que les
les choses sont assez claires le le
Hamas d'ailleurs l'a dit dès le premier
jour nous avons suffisamment d'otag
israéliens pour obtenir la libération de
tous les détenus palestiniens on sait
qu'il y en a à peu près 45000 donc là
ils vont libérer sur 4 jours si tout se
passe bien une cinquantaine de Tage
israélien une dizaine une douzaine par
jour on croit comprendre qu'en
contreparti il y aurit 150 détenus
palestiniens qui sortiraient des prisons
la trêve va s'arrêter dans 4 jours
ensuite il y aura de nouveau des des
affrontements des combats et de nouveau
il y aura probablement des négociations
hein parce que le Qatar a bien dit que
c'était une première étape on parle de
de de possibilité de reconduire cette
trait donc voilà ce qu'il faudrait
espérer parce que je ne pense pas euh et
je suis pas le seul que Israël arrivera
comme il l'a souhaité comme il le
souhaite à éradiquer militairement et
politiquement le le Hamas donc il faut
souhaiter que Israël arrive à à à à
affaiblir durablement le Hamas pour
qu'il ne représente plus une menace
comme c'était le cas avant le 7 octobre
mais il faut il faut souhaiter que que
d'autres otages soi libérés et que les
les pauses humanitaires permettent à la
population de Gaza de de pouvoir un
petit peu respirer et cetera et qu'on a
qu'on arrive vers un chemin de de de
sortie de cette de cette guerre et parce
qu'il faudra penser aussi à
l'après-gerre qui est un autre défi très
important c'est c'est une pause
effectivement de 4 jours alors c'est 4
jours pleins donc c'est 5 jours au total
et ce qui est prévu aussi c'est que
pendant ces 45 jours et bien le Hamas va
tenter c'est ce qu'ils disent hein de
chercher où sont les autres otages comme
si ils savaient pas exactement où se
trouvaient les autres otages et les
discussions vont continuer à raison de
10 otages supplémentaires libérés euh
pour un jour de trêve supplémentaire
donc ça peut nous entraîner comme ça
pendant une à deux semaines le Hamas qui
va sans doute effectivement utiliser ce
temps pour se repositionner pour se
réarmer Israël est au courant dans ce
dans cet accord qui a été conclu aussi
il faut le dire c'est que laamas a
obtenu que les drones de surveillance
israélien ne survole pas la bande de
Gaza pendant 6h donc c'est beaucoup
c'est c'est important Israël a tenté et
bien de de de mettre de côté cette
condition finalement ça pas été euh
obtenu euh juste le cesser le feu juste
je précise le CESS feu devrait commencer
demain 7h à raison effectivement de 10
otages libérés euh chaque jour première
étape c'est la libération des otages
israéliens qui seront remis à la croix-
rouge ensuite ils devront franchir la
frontière avec Israël et seulement à ce
moment-là israël va libérer les
prisonners Palestiniens alors Israël a
publié ce matin la liste alors ils ont
publié une liste de 300 prisonniers
palestiniens dans ces 300 on trouve un
peu de tout on trouve effectivement des
des alors c'est des femmes et des
enfants et des adolescents qui ont jeté
des cailloux sur des soldats mais aussi
qui ont posé des bonsbes qui ont
vraiment participer à des à des attates
terroristes donc il y a un peu tout dans
cette liste et dernier point je termine
là-dessus c'est que pourquoi le CCF
commencera demain seulement c'est que
pour des raisons juridiques les
Israéliens ont 24 heures pour faire
appel de la décision du gouvernement de
de de de signer cet accord avec le Hamas
c'est-à-dire si les Israéliens estiment
que cette libération met leur vie en
danger bien ils peuvent faire appel
devant la Cour suprême pour protester
contre cet accord qui a été donc signé
et validé par le le cabinet militaire et
le gouvernement israélien hier Francis
Pinard sur cet
accordcoutz je ne suis pas en
charge de la politique
israélienne donc mais est-ce que c'est
une première porte de sortie de C on
rappelle qu'il y a des otages français
peut on ne peut que se réjouir que des
gens qui ont été
été des civils qui ont été enlevés ce
sont des otages ce sont c'est le
banditisme du Hamas donc qui soit libéré
c'est plutôt rassurant pour eux pour
leur famille moi je pense évidemment sur
le plan humain que toute personne qui a
un otage dans sa famille tient
évidemment à le récupérer maintenant
politiquement le Hamas va
essayer de gagner du temps et donc la
question qui se pose mais ça ça ne
m'appartient pas c'est est-ce que Israël
peut se permettre que le Hamas s'en
sorte à si bon compte sur le plan
psychologique Israël était de la
puissance
militaire c'est comme le 11 septembre le
7 octobre c'est devenu le colosse au
pied d'argile est-ce que à ce moment-là
ça doit passer par une victoire
militaire éclatante pour laver l'affront
et repartir sur de bonnes base oou
est-ce que ça doit rester quelqu'un qui
a été confronté à sa faiblesse mais ça
c'est c'est la réponse des Israéliens ça
ne peut pas être la nôre mais ce sera un
vrai sujet pour eux voilà mais parce que
George malbr est-ce qu'il y a un risque
Steve le rappelez il y a pas de survol
de drone pendant 6h est-ce qu'il y a un
risque le Hamas profite de C trêv pour
se réarmer et pour se renforcer se
réarmer je pense qu'il a pas à se
réarmer ses stocks d'armes sont déjà
dans les tunnels il va simplement en
profiter de pour pour pour pour se
réorganiser mais on est dans une guerre
dans une Guer on est dans la guerre et
donc il y a pas de chose sympathique et
donc je ve dire quand vous avez 240
otages ça vous donne un sacré levier et
on on voit bien dans la communication
israélienne ce matin Benyamin Nanou ne
parle pas de libération des détenus
palestiniens en Israël voilà ça a changé
le les termes de la de l'affrontement
cette cette prise d' Tage massive et et
elle va elle va elle va elle va
continuer ça va parce que ça va être un
élément de la négociation
50 s's en on 250 ça veut dire 5
séquences sachant que je suis pas un
devin mais je je je connais semaines oui
pe nous enter jusquà 3 semaines à raison
de 10ag parour voilà voilà et s'il y a
pas de complication sachant que le Hamas
l'a déjà plus ou moins dit je pense et
là qu'ils le feront ils garderont pour
la fin les Israéliens détenus qui sont
des haut gradés de l'armée israélienne
en disant voilà bah on a obtenu pour
l'instant x libération de détenus
palestiniens en Israël maintenant on a
les gros poissons bah discutons et là ça
risque de prendre beaucoup de temps de
de temps parce que parce que ça va être
très compliqué mais mais on est on est
dans ce chemin-là et il faut souhaiter
que ça soit mené effectivement en
parallèle avec une avec une poursuite de
l'offensive militaire israélienne mais
mais ça va être compliqué pour Israël
c'est déjà compliqué on voit déjà que
les Américains qui sont vraiment
derrière euh mgurk le représente
l'envoyé spécial américain pour le
Moyen-Orient a dit quelque chose
d'intéressant il y a une semaine à un
forum à Manama il a dit l'objectif c'est
c'est de dégrader le Hamas ça n'est plus
d'éradiquer le Hamas parce que
militairement ils ne vont pas y arriver
les Israéliens le savent je pense mais
il faut lui infliger suffisemment de cou
pour qu'il ne puisse pas se relever la
tête immédiatement après donc voilà on
est on est rentré maintenant c'est une
une nouvelle étape dans ce conflit qui
va être un mélange je pense d'action
militaire de poursuite de l'action
militaire israélienne de de de de de
d'action militaire du du Hamas et puis
de d'apaisement avec ces libérations
contre des pause contre l'acheminement
de l'aide humanitaire pour la population
de Gaza et donc il y aura des il y aura
probablement des crises parce qu'il y a
un des deux camps qui va pas respecter
sa parole mais on est rentré dans dans
une autre phase pour vous il sera il
sera pas forcément respecté cet accord
non mais il sera il sera respecté parce
qu'il y a des garants mais dans une
crise de Tage fa en sorte de
l'interpréter au ses intérêts il peut y
avoir toujours il y aura bien le Hamas
qui va essayer de de piéger Israël
peut-être qu'Israël essayera de piéger
Hamas mais bon ça c'est je dirais c'est
la chorégraphie habituelle d' de
libération d'age qu'en 2014
effectivement pendant un cesser de feu
un soldat israélien avait été kidnappé
et on sait toujours pas où il se trouve
actuellement merci merci beaucoup si
vous voulez bien rester avec nous on va
regarder ce qu' à la une de nos
quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux
estive à la une de la presse régionale
ce matin le crfcœur des restos oui on va
voir ce qu' est à la Une de corps ce
matin la 39e campagne des Restos du cœur
a débuté hier elle est marqué par des
difficultés financières inédites
l'association est obligée de revoir la
baisse et distribution malgré des
demandes en hausse encore ce sont plus
de 3000 personnes qui bénéficient de
l'aide des restos cette année le nombre
de repas distribués par personne va
diminuer on l'attend depuis longtemps
elle arrive ça y est la loi grand âge
elle été promise par Emmanuel Macron en
2018 promesse rester lettre morte mais
Elisabeth borne annonce finalement une
loi pluriannuelle sur le grand âge et
l'autonomie ça sera pour 2024 c'est la
Une des DNA pourquoi parce qu'éisabeth
borne a rencontré les lecteurs du
journal à l'occasion de son déplacement
à Strasbourg les échanges sont à lire
dans le journal la PR première ministre
revient notamment sur ses engagements
européens manière aussi peut-être de
préparer les élections à venir du mois
de juin vent de panique dans les rues de
3 oui c'est à la Une de l'Est éclair
lundi un mineur d'origine guinéenne a
été interpellé par la police il était
armé de plusieurs couteaux et menacé les
passes en criéant Allah Akbar la scène
s'est déroulée à proximité de sites
accueillant des élèves et des étudiants
l'homme serait un mineur isolé hébergé
dans un foyer de la ville plus de peur
que de mal aucun blessé n'est à déploré
l'enquête de la police va maintenant se
poursuivre sujet plus léger les arnaques
du Black Friday oui le télégram nous
aide à éviter les pièges une étude alors
Black Friday c'est c'est vendredi hein
une étude montre que 35 % des les
articles vendus le jour du Black Friday
sont plus chers qu'un mois auparavant
c'est contraire à la loi qui organise
les promos le Black Friday représente
beaucoup d'argent puisque les les
Français puisqu'en France c'est près de
400 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires pour les commerçants en
moyenne 259 € sont dépensés par les
Français voilà avant d'acheter liser le
télégram ça y est c'est aujourd'hui
c'est aujourd'hui la sortie du film de
ride les SCOT sur Napoléon sort ce
mercredi la Une de La Provence qui fait
de Napoléon certes un Corse Orian mais
un Corse qui a été propulsé sur le
devant de la scène par la Provence par
la région Provence c'est là que tout a
commencé pour lui ses premières
victoires son premier amour ses
premières chimèr article passionnant à
lire dans La Provence on retrouve aussi
une interview de l'acteur qui joue
Napoléon joain phéix merci beaucoup
merci Steve merci Francis piner d'être
venu merci beaucoup Georg mal Bruno on
regarde la Une de votre journal Le
Figaro c'est la loi immigration
d'armanin à la manœuvre à l'Assemblée
c'est à la Une du Figaro aujourd'hui
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous à 15h la séance de
question d'actualité au Gouvernement et
puis à 18h Thomas Huc sens public très
bonne journée
y